modeling data relationships is one of
the single most important concerns for
an app developer in this episode I'm
going to show you how to build a
five-star review system from scratch
using the new fire stored document
database and angular my goal is to give
you a good foundation for building
many-to-many relationships in a no
sequel back-end environment the reason I
chose a five-star review system for this
episode is because the underlying
concepts can be applied to many
different features such as Facebook
Likes reddit votes Instagram hearts and
many other concepts similar to those one
of the most important best practices
with firestore is to create big
collections and small documents to build
this feature we're going to have three
collections in the root of the database
so this first collection is a user's
collection and the only attribute on the
document itself is the display name I
won't have time to cover user
authentication in this video but if
you're new to my channel make sure to
check out my previous firestore Roth
video to get up to speed on that so back
to the database our primary goal here is
to create a relationship between users
and movies through the Stars collection
so if you look at our movies document it
just has the image title and plot of the
movie if we jump over to the Stars
collection you'll see that's where all
the relational data is cat
each star document will save the movie
ID as well as the user ID and the value
of the rating and then because a user
can only post one review for each movie
I've also created a custom ID here to
ensure that there's no accidental data
duplication so we create the document ID
by concatenating that movie ID to the
user ID separated by an underscore and
you'll see this more once we get into
angular if you come from a sequel
background this is very similar to a
many-to-many through relationship so now
I'm jumping into my angular project I'm
assuming you have angularfire to version
5 installed what I'm going to be doing
today is to creating a very generic
middleman service that can connect
relationships between any two documents
to focus on the relationship aspect of
this feature I'm going to just hard code
a user document and movie document
directly in the app component so I'll
set up a variable for the user document
and movie document which are both
angular firestore document types and
then we'll also set another variable for
the user and the movie as an observable
then during ng on
we'll go ahead and load the documents so
in this case I'm just going to hard code
a user ID in here but in the real world
you would get this from an off service
or some other off mechanism and it'll do
the exact same thing for a movie
document but I'd like to point out that
these two documents never contain any
information about the other party it's
all handled through the middleman star
document that we're going to create
later then to turn these references into
observables we call value changes on
each of the documents we can get the
movie ID or user ID on the angularfire
document itself so we can set up a
getter here and then on the angularfire
store document we can call ref ID more
than anything setting up the getter just
helps clean up the code once we get to
the HTML so inside the app component
HTML I'm going to unwrap the movies
observable and I do that by just calling
movie async and then set it as a
template variable of M with that we can
display a title and display the image
URL as well as the movie plot and we'll
come back to this later after we create
the star review component but before we
do that we're first going to build our
service so run ng generate service star
and make sure to specify the app module
the goal of our service is to
communicate with firestore to build that
middle relationship in the star
collection so after importing
angularfire store i'm going to create an
interface here just to reinforce what a
start is so a star is just going to be
the user ID movie ID and then a value
for the star which brings us from 0.5 to
5 from there we can add angularfire
store to the constructor with that done
I want to show you why I have stars as a
root collection and not a sub collection
under users or movies so let's say we
wanted to get all of the movies that a
user has starred we could do that by
calling collection stars then use the
query callback with where to filter them
by the user ID firestore will
automatically index by the user ID so
this will be a fast query even if it's a
massive collection and then in this case
here we want to return the observable of
this query so we just call value changes
on it now the reason it's a root
collection is because we want to query
stars by their movie ID as well so we
can do the exact same thing just
watching out the user ID for the movie
ID if stars were nested as a sub
collection we'd be able to make one of
these queries but not both of them the
last thing we need from our service is
to set the actual relationship so we'll
create a method here that takes a user
ID movie ID and value of the star review
so we'll go ahead and set that to a
JavaScript object type to our star
interface then we can use this data to
also create a custom ID for our document
so I'm going to set that up as user ID
underscore movie ID this technique will
ensure that you don't have any data
duplication assuming you have unique
user IDs and movie IDs it also provides
a quick way to query a star document if
you already have a movie ID and user ID
somewhere else in your code so the only
thing left to do is make a reference to
this path and then call set with star
data that's what we need for now but you
might also want to add a delete method
if you want users to be able to remove
their past stars that's it for the
service now we can move on to the star
review component so after it's been
generated let's go ahead and first add
it to the app component so we're going
to pass it a movie ID and a user ID from
the parent component if you want to
learn more about this check out my
sharing data with components video but
all we're doing here is passing the
movie ID and user ID strings from the
parent to the child and we'll set that
up with the input decorator here in the
type script in just a second inside the
star review type script we'll go ahead
and import the service as well as the
input decorator from angular core then
we can declare our user ID and movie ID
variables with the decorator this just
tells angular to allow these variables
to be passed indirectly through the HTML
before we go any further let's look a
little closer at how this app works so
we have a current user here on the left
and then a movie on the right and if a
movie has no reviews it just says not
reviewed here the user can then hover
over the stars and when they click it it
will actually update the data in
firebase and it will also calculate the
average rating among all users that have
starred this movie so the next step will
be to set up by a variable for the Stars
observable then I'm going to set a
separate observable for the average
rating and we can use our star service
during ng on a net to retrieve the
actual observable list so in this case
we want to show all of the movie stars
so we just called it movie stars with
movie ID then we can use the rxjs map
operator to break this down into an
average rating after a calling map we're
going to have an observable array of
objects
so first we'll map these objects down to
just their number values in other words
the value that users have rated them and
then with that array of numbers we can
then reduce it down to its average this
code might look kind of ugly but this is
the standard way that you would get the
average of an array in plain JavaScript
and if that array is empty we're just
going to say not reviewed that takes
care of the observables but now we need
an event handler that will update
firestore when the user clicks on the
star icon so we already have the method
set up in the service so we just have to
pass the event handler a value and then
it will use the user ID movie ID and
that value to update firestore so let's
jump over to the HTML and put this all
together so for the average rating we
can just call async and we're good to go
it's already been mapped down to the
value that we want to show other users
that have starred a movie we can loop
over the star observable with the async
pipe and then just display some data
about that particular star so we'll say
this user ID gave this movie X amount of
stars so now we can actually build that
form where the user updates their star
rating a lot of this is CSS that I'm not
going to cover but you can get the full
code at the lesson link in the
description so we set up an NG container
here which basically allows you to loop
over something without affecting the Dom
in this case I'm just going to loop over
the integers of 5 through 1 I set up
this loop so they only have to create
two input fields rather than 10 so the
first inputs going to represent a full
star so what we can do is pass the
number down to our start handler so if
the user clicks the fifth star it'll
send a 5 star review up to firestorm and
then we need to set up an ID which is
different for each one so we'll just say
star plus whatever number we're looping
over and these are just HTML radio
buttons with some fancy CSS styling
each input also has a label and it's
important that the four attribute
matches the ID on the input exactly to
create a half star we can duplicate this
process we just have to subtract 0.5
from each number so when we call the
start handler will subtract 0.5 then we
also have different CSS styles on the
half star so that's why we have them
separated as two different inputs like
this the CSS to make this look good on
the front end is actually based on a
code pin so I'll have a link for that in
the description and you can also get the
full code at angular firebase com
so if we check it out on the front end
you can see we have the movie here with
just one average rating of 2.5 if we had
another 5 star rating that average
changes in real-time to 3.75 then if we
go ahead and add another review this
time with firestore pulled up you can
see that the values are being saved in
the back end and real-time as well
that's it four star ratings with angular
and firestorm if this video helped you
please like and subscribe and if you
want to take your app to the next level
with exclusive pro con tent consider
becoming a pro member at angular
firebase com
thanks for watching and I'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]